- [Announcer] This video
is brought to you by Wren.
(upbeat music)
What's up, everybody? Michael here.
I don't know about you,
but in this chaotic world, I've
found there's no better cure
for ongoing feelings of dread than,
no, not a carton of Cherry Garcia,
but some dopamine-inducing videos
of people acting like dogs.
I'm talking about TikTok.
As of last year, the app
had 1 billion active users,
making it one of the
largest and fastest growing
social media platforms.
But as the app and its algorithm
become more ubiquitous,
we're learning in real time
how it's affecting our society
and even our brains.
And some worry it's
doing so for the worst.
- Who created the air fryer?
Really?
Really, because I can't do it anymore.
- Are these concerns
legit or a tad overblown?
Let's find out in this Wisecrack edition,
is TikTok evil?
But before we dive in,
I wanna tell you about
this video sponsor, Wren.
When I look at the news lately,
things are not great in a lot of ways.
But among them is the ever looming threat
of climate disaster.
And it's easy to feel helpless,
but Wren is an easy way
to help turn your concern
for the climate into tangible action.
First, Wren's easy quiz helps
you calculate the exact size
of your carbon footprint.
They'll ask you about
things like your diet,
your travel habits, and
other lifestyle basics.
From there, they suggest ways
for you to reduce your impact
on the environment right off the bat.
For instance,
I should really stop
driving short distances
to pick up things like burritos
when I could just walk.
But because nobody's carbon
footprint can be zero,
Wren also offsets your remaining footprint
with their targeted climate initiatives.
As someone who lives in California,
I was really impressed with
Wren's Biochar project,
which removes dead trees
from Fredwood forest and
high fire risk areas.
They turn these trees into biochar,
a stable form of carbon that
lasts for thousands of years.
And while I'm extra pumped
about Wren's projects
that are local to me,
their work resonates around the world.
There's their mineral weathering project
in Scotland, for instance,
which turns atmospheric
carbon into solid rock,
all using accelerated
natural geological processes,
which is cool and all,
but this project also includes a brigade
of wooly pigs who prepare
the soil for regrowth,
and they are just so adorable.
Once you sign up to make
a monthly contribution
that will be used to offset
your carbon footprint,
you'll receive monthly updates
from the projects you support.
So you will actually see the
impact that you are making.
Wren has pledge to plant 10 extra trees
for the first 100 people who sign up
using our referral link.
So go to wren.co/start/wisecrack
to join us in saving the rainforest
and fighting the climate crisis.
That's wren.co/start/wisecrack.
And now, back to the show.
There's a lot of debate
about whether TikTok
is a societal good or a societal evil.
On the downside,
it's been shown to increase
anxiety, depression,
and body image issues.
And though, I don't know, it
also allows a Chinese company
to collect your personal data and possibly
maybe collude with the
Chinese government for funds,
censorship, or propaganda reasons,
then again, Facebook
misinformation played a key role
in influencing elections,
but Hey, who's keeping score?
But TikTok, isn't all bad.
It's great for making friends
and expanding your community
of people with a niche interest
like a Midwest mom cooking hacks.
Plus, it's an accessible creative outlet
that's super entertaining.
- [Woman] Look at the butterfly.
- That was stupid.
- [Micheal] I mean, where
else could you see this?
(dramatic music)
Or this?
- I added these tassels to it,
and our lives have never been the same.
- Or this?
(bouncy music)
I could go on for literal
hours, but I'll stop now.
And it's this level of
addiction that sets TikTok apart
from other social media platforms.
TikTok has a top-of-the-line algorithm
that consistently gives you what you want.
This never-ending quest for dopamine
is what some researchers now
refer to as TikTok brain.
(dramatic music)
And parents and experts are worried
about the impact it has on
kids' shrinking attention spans.
TikTok hasn't been around long enough
for researchers to discern
whether it permanently alters
or damages kids' brains, but
we couldn't help but notice
these concerns are reminiscent of debates
over whether violent video
games cause increased aggression
or whether heavy metal gives
you an unquenchable thirst
for goat blood.
So is it possible we're projecting
our deeply embedded
societal fears onto TikTok?
Odds are yes.
Fear almost always rides on the
coattails of new technology.
For example, Plato and Socrates
both believed writing would
destroy the oral tradition
and make everyone forgetful.
When trains were first invented,
everyone thought centrifugal force
would make women's uterus fly out.
They didn't do that.
And in the late 19th century,
experts warned that riding
a bicycle could result
in bicycle face, a
condition where your face
would permanently look
blown back by a mighty wind.
There was even a CNN
article published in 2005
that said email hurt the
IQ more than marijuana.
These hypotheses all beg the question.
Why are we so freaked out by technology?
And is TikTok the latest
centrifugal uterus ejecting force
in human development?
Prior to the 18th century,
science and technology were separate
non-threatening entities.
Science was mostly based in heady theories
while technology was composed of skills
passed down through the generations
like blacksmithing or cobbling.
Then in a classic romcom
meet cute scenario,
18th century scientists,
Priestley and Lavoisier,
introduced these fields to each other
via chemical discoveries
that led to large scale electricity.
Just like that, science
had practical applications
and technology had a role
in scientific progress.
They completed each other.
By the beginning of the 19th century,
everyone was hyped on
this new technology thing.
Scientists and craftsman
intersected to create the engineer
and the world seemed
full of possibilities.
Flying machines, submarines,
and the ability to talk to the dead
were surely just around the corner, right?
Technology transformed into a chiral
for the human condition,
society, and the world,
which is exactly how I
used to feel about improv.
Yes, and much like improv,
the movement picked up
cult level enthusiasm.
It became known as positivism.
Auguste Comte, a French
philosopher and positivist,
dreamed of a utopian society
where all the best
scientists were in power
and that they unified everyone
through scientific and political progress.
If that were true today,
we'd be reciting the scientific method
instead of the pledge of allegiance,
which when I really think
about it, wouldn't be so bad.
Unfortunately, before this
utopia could take shape,
people's enthusiasm and
excitement for technology
took a turn for the worse.
The start of the Industrial Revolution
kicked off a rise in
collective tech anxiety.
The landscape of people's lives,
literally and figuratively,
seemed to transform overnight.
The new bourgeois emerged,
and as they profited off new technologies,
they didn't promote peace,
fairness, and equality
like people expected.
Instead, they scooped up
their money without regard
for how it affected people around them.
Meanwhile, workers were
afraid of losing their jobs
to machines and didn't
have any social protections
if that did happen.
People's anxiety over tech
boiled down to three big questions.
One, could technology be destructive
in the hands of the wrong people?
Two, could this power
make humans into gods?
And three, could humans
be automated out of a job
or purpose?
Then a couple of world wars came around,
you may have heard of them,
and answered those first two questions
with a resounding yes.
It became crystal clear that humans could
and would use science and technology
to kill millions of people.
While the rise of the
internet in Silicon Valley
revived a vision of technological utopia,
anxiety surrounding tech
would never vanish completely.
Something about lightning fast innovation
continues to freak a lot of us out.
Philosophers included, Martin Heidegger,
a German philosopher who we
must note was in the Nazi Party,
was one of the first thinkers
to associate technology
with the devastation of humanity's desire
for truth and meaning.
Heidegger theorized that
technology pulls us away
from the true meaning of human existence,
which he called dasein,
which describes our way
of being in the world,
always marked by the fact
that our being is oriented
towards our inevitable
finitude, i.e. our death.
In other words,
Heidegger thought that when
we stop looking for meaning
and things like art and poetry
and instead rely on technology
to make sense of the world,
things start to have a
primarily instrumental value.
The next generation of German philosophers
doubled down on this idea.
The Frankfurt School theorized
that post-war capitalist societies
could become a kind of
invisible totalitarianism
founded on the domination of
technology-fueled consumerism.
People would slowly lose their willpower
and be controlled through the
manipulation of their desires.
You know, like how TikTok does.
Jurgen Habermas,
one of the last living members
at the Frankfurt School,
believed technology has its own logic
and threatens to destroy
not only politics,
culture, and human life, but the world.
Because, again, technology
can pull us away
from both the essence of
our human subjectivity
and our desire to find meaning
beyond profit and productivity.
But as it turns out,
technology hasn't
destroyed everything yet,
except for my relationship
with my uncle Rob
after he kept posting on Facebook.
We can now communicate with
far-flowing friends and family
more easily than ever
before, which is rad, again,
except for with my uncle Rob.
we can have a lifesaving
bacon, egg, and cheese
sent to our homes with the tap of a button
As we ride in bed hungover.
Hell, you can even get a pacemaker
that tracks your cardiac health
and sends potentially
life saving status updates
to your doctor.
But in spite of countless
net positive developments,
new innovations like TikTok
can still freak us out.
And the anxiety around
tech is alive and well.
And some of this is valid.
For one, social media and
other database innovations
collect, circulate, share,
and profit off of our data
on a global level.
It's scary when our personal data is used
for purposes outside of our control.
It's double scary when TikTok's algorithm
can so accurately predict
and control our behavior.
If technology can make us
watch cat videos for hours,
what's to stop it from taking
over our lives completely?
And what happens when
the videos it serves us
aren't just fun time wasters,
but less fun conspiracy theories?
Now, obviously, misinformation clogs up
every social media platform
as the Uncle robs of the Facebook world
unite to convince you that
there's now a microchip
in your happily vaccinated arm.
but journalist and author,
Chris Stokel-Walker
argues that TikTok's algorithm,
coupled with the immediacy of its format,
makes it especially
right for misinformation.
He writes, "Emotive videos
can cause people to overlook
whether or not information is legitimate."
This can have real consequences.
Analysis for media from NewsGuard
determined that misinformation about COVID
reached a staggering
eight out of nine children
after just 35 minutes on the app.
Many adults are concerned in particular
about potentially misleading videos
on what's known as therapy tok.
This is a trend in which Gen Z's
self-diagnosis mental disorders,
after watching influencer's videos
chronicling their own struggles.
Experts are split on
whether this is good or bad.
On the one hand,
influencers help normalize
discussions around mental health,
but on the other, misdiagnosing
mental health issues
can have serious consequences.
To say nothing about the apps
that are making it easier
than ever for young people
to get psych meds,
they may or may not need
sent directly to their homes.
However, what's at the crux of this issue
is our very human tendency
to trust popular people,
even if they have no idea
what they're talking about.
Historically, the most
popular people around
have been celebrities,
and the masses have loved
following their examples.
Whether they're channeling
their inner Lord Byrons
with roughly shirts,
raising AIDS awareness
like Bono and Angelina Jolie,
or drinking high-end tequila
because George Clooney
and his buddies make it.
But celebrity influence can also backfire.
Remember Jenny McCarthy?
Well, back in 2005, she used
her expertise as a parent
to widely propagate the idea
that the MMR vaccine
caused her son's autism.
Even today, you might have
noticed that many Americans
still aren't sure about vaccines.
But whether you're turning to Tom Brady
for nutritional advice, JLo
for her hair care routine,
or buying a Subway foot long
because Steph Curry told you to,
at the end of the day, celebrities,
they're just like us is
a punchline for a reason.
They are not like us.
So where does a feeling of
true trust and kinship exist
in today's media landscape?
TikTok, of course, where
folks who are just like you
are able to have a
celebrity-like influence
just by virtue of being themselves.
As you take in the sheer volume of content
from your favorite creators,
it's easy to form what's called
a parasocial relationship with them,
i.e. one in which you feel like
you already know that person in real life,
even though they have no idea you exist.
What's more, scholars Bhandari and Bimo
suggested in their analysis of TikTok
that in contrast to other
social media platforms,
"The crux of interaction
is not between users
and their social network, but
between a user in what we call
an algorithmized version of self."
So essentially,
TikTok compounds these
parasocial relationships
with such algorithmic precision,
but not only are you looking
at your favorite creator,
but it also feels like
you're looking into a mirror
at yourself.
You might be asking yourself,
"Why are we, as a human race,
predisposed to listening to
celebrities and influencers
instead of qualified experts?"
Well, there are evolutionary
and psychological reasons
behind why we trust who we trust.
As far as influencers are concerned,
we often fall victim to prestige,
biased, social learning.
In basic terms, this is
the tendency to trust
and learn from people who
have gained attention,
respect, and admiration for
success in a particular domain.
In this case, TikTok
subscribers and views.
This adaptive social learning strategy
developed as a shortcut to
identifying group members
who are thriving without needing to assess
a 16-year-old superstar's
individual merits.
So is potentially harmful
and dangerous misinformation
being spread on TikTok?
Absolutely.
But again, this isn't unique to TikTok.
And Gen Z's reliance on therapy
tok for advice and guidance
isn't what's standing in the way
of them seeking mental healthcare.
As many have pointed out,
inaccessibility to mental healthcare
is what drives young people
to therapy tok for answers
in the first place.
So far, TikTok doesn't
seem particularly evil,
but what about TikTok sides,
AKA little niche communities
or echo chambers on the app?
Could these result in greater
political polarization?
Not really.
Ironically, political polarization
currently occurs most in generations
that use social media
the least, AKA the olds.
Plus, political polarization
has been growing in the US
since the 1970s,
long before Noodles
ever had a no bones day.
But hey, it's a lot easier to blame TikTok
than to address the real
problems behind polarization
like growing income equality
lack of access to education,
resistance to multiculturalism
and globalization,
stagnant wages, and Taco
Bell continuing to tease us
with the return of the Mexican pizza.
So then TikTok could and
probably does cause polarization,
but it's probably not the main culprit.
In other words, human
behavior may be to blame
and that makes us uncomfortable,
so we use TikTok as a scapegoat
for serious societal issues.
For example, there are lots
of studies floating around
arguing that social media
increases anxiety, depression,
and poor self-esteem.
The problem is many of
those are correlational.
Researchers sort people into two groups;
people who consume TikTok
and people who suffer from
anxiety and depression.
Then they check the Venn diagram
to see who's at the center.
If it's enough people, eureka,
TikTok must cause all
sorts of mental illnesses.
Yeah, but not really.
Correlational studies only tell us
these two groups are interconnected.
They don't tell us whether
TikTok or depression
is the chicken or the egg,
but longitudinal studies
on social media do.
These aren't as common
because longitudinal studies
take more time and money,
and unless you're Santa
Claus, it's not exactly cheap
to track thousands of kids over the years.
However, researchers from
Brigham Young University,
Finland and Canada,
were able to secure the
funding for this very purpose
and found no true correlation
between social media and
anxiety and depression.
Conversely, German and Canadian studies
found depressed and or anxious people
were more likely to use social media,
and that depressive
symptoms could even predict
social media usage.
This could indicate
that people dealing with mental illnesses
might be drawn to the hyper
stimulation, dopamine rewards,
and so on that social media facilitates.
All of this strongly suggests
that our society's anxiety
and depression is the chicken
and social media is the egg.
So yes,
TikTok is absolutely changing
the social media landscape,
but it's not fundamentally changing us.
In a tale as old as time, we've
hyper-focused on technology
and ignored the power
of our own psychology.
To be clear, we're not
trying to say that TikTok
is a societal good.
As we discussed in our previous episode
on Elon's potential
acquisition of Twitter,
calling platforms good or bad
is kind of missing the point.
TikTok is used by influencers
and wanna-be influencers.
It's used by nurses,
teachers, and therapists.
It's also used by, say,
radical extremists.
However, the knee jerk
reaction to judge it
as inherently evil or
dangerous is misguided.
A more apt description might
be TikTok is chaotic neutral.
The reality is that
TikTok is a free product
whose chief source of
income is ad revenue.
And the only way to increase that income
is to keep people on the
app for as long as possible.
Our attention is a valuable resource
and boy, oh boy, is it in demand.
In this new attention economy,
focus is our scarcest and
most valuable resource.
So how do we keep social
media companies like TikTok
from stealing it right
out of our time wallets?
Author Mark Manson
proposes an attention diet
where we identify worthwhile
information in relationships,
cut out the junk, and cultivate habits
that foster deeper focus
and longer attention spans.
The goal is to focus on
what adds value to your life
by being more intentional
about what we consume on social media
and how long we spend there.
This is obviously easier said than done.
But maybe, just maybe, if we
can build our mental fortitude
like we build our imaginary
investment portfolios,
we might just be able to
beat the algorithm after all.
But what do you guys think?
Can we win our attention back
from the world's most effective algorithm?
Do we even want our attention back
if it means being bored as?
Let us know what you
think in the comments.
Big thanks to our patrons
for all your support,
and be sure to check out
our new Patreon features.
Also, check out our new
stream, Wisecrack Live.
It happens every Thursday,
11:00 a.m. Pacific.
Hit that subscribe button
like you're tapping the
do not disturb button
and touching some grass,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
As always, thanks for watching, later.
(upbeat music)